Seed Stitch and Moss Stitch are very popular
in the handknitting world.
They are reversible and highly textured.
These stitches can be problematic
for machine knitters since our machines
don't form both knit
and purl stitches easily.
Seed Stich alternates knit and purl stitches every row.
Moss stitch alternates knit
and purl stitches every other row.
If you are lucky enough to have a brother
standard gauge machine with a G-carriage,
the turtle can make quick
work of the stitch pattern.
For small sections,
hand manipulation is an option.
For Seed Stitch, reform
every other needle, every other
row alternating the stitches.
For Moss Sttich reform every other needle,
every two rows,
alternating every two rows.
If you have a Ribber,
you might consider transferring the Seed
or Moss Stitches between the beds
to form the knit and purl stitches.
Either way, when you're hand manipulating
this type of stitch pattern,
it can be time-consuming,
but given in small doses,
it can be well worth the effort.